on passe toujours pas la sacristie ont
d'abord pour l'os de dionysos bout canon
scié pas de quartier sur les célébrités
les ai je bien descendu lui un christian
laborde bonsoir bonsoir
tu étais professeur de français de
gascon dans une école il s'appelle notre
dame de garaison ya à peu près 15 cents
élèves qui date de 1847 fin le truc
vraiment sérieux et bétonné près de
lannemezan dans les hautes pyrénées et
le 5 mars 1987 et publié un bouquin qui
s'appelle l'os de dionysos aux éditions
et chez on va dire d'abord pourquoi
l'offre du monde
et bien parce que c'est un d'abord le
titre est une simple percussions verbal
je crois que je ne sais pas si a
toujours un sens dans un titre avait en
tout cas la lauze de dionysos ça ce sont
les très bien et puis en plus c'était un
clin d'oeil à henri iv qui parlant de
son sexe visé jusqu'à 40 ans j'ai cru
que c'était non voilà ce que je fais
quand on doit dire mon cher christian
alors qu'il a été interdit le 12 mars
c'est à dire sept jours après la
parution du livre a été interdit par le
tribunal de tarbes et le 30 mars
la r2 87 ça a été confirmé par le
tribunal de d'appel de pau je crois
qu'il ya des portrait extrêmement
virulent et effectivement les autorités
du collège où j'ai enseigné dans la
mesure où un écrivain écrit forcément de
quelque part ils ont fait évidemment une
lecture très biographique du livre eh
bien ils ont estimé que je m'y attaquer
donc leur directrice et à travers elle
les ce qu'ils appelaient les principes
fondateurs de l'école chrétien mais ça
va blasphème lubricité il faut regarder
roland question voilà paganisme enfin
ils sont pas une main morte
alors que eux en pot ces mots je crois
que con
qu'un prêtre
par le dépôt ganis mhz et de blasphème
site je dirais que c'est un langage qui
a sa place dans sa bouche i le problème
c'est que ce langage là est devenu le
langage des juges et america pas été
content que je quitte à virer
l'éducation nationale oui les seuls qui
ont un peu reculé
combien de diass comme les jésuites
quand tu es allé les voir c'est à
toulouse
tout à fait il tendit mais non j'ai déjà
trente mille bouquin le plus simple
moins de poids la haie lors le
concernant monory lui cette saison chef
de cabinet qui lui a traduit le livre et
quand la traduction est achevée il ya
une phrase qui les a choqués sert ha ha
ha voie hiérarchique un dur et c'est
bien
et cette percussion verbale a
profondément choqué les autorités
universitaires j'ai donc se retrouver à
la rue et j'ai trouvé refuge est en tête
appuyée de pornographie forcément chez
des gisements ça commence par une phase
rigolote s'est longtemps je me suis
branler de bonheur qu'elle à la reprise
de la phrase du début de la recherche et
le juge qui a condamné s'appelle soit
c'est vrai ça c'est absolument tenter ce
prix mais c'est à dire que nous sommes
je crois que là dans cette affaire
dionysos d'un assez dans cette histoire
d'os précisément je crois que ce qui m'a
frappé c'est à côté de l'aspect odieux
de la censure c'est de voir comment des
juges écrivait la légende
effectivement avec une phrase de
proustienne ce retour est du côté de
chez swann ouais voilà que moi je criais
de se faire ces deux récits sur ça cela
dit je ne garde pas d'une demande
passage devant le tribunal de
de pau je ne garde pas un souvenir
littéraire quand tu dis le tabernacle et
dans l'arrêt j'ai là que red je me signe
devant le trou et je communie dans
l'orifice bon littérairement sais ce que
c'est mais bon c'est vrai quand on est
prof dans une école de pure et simple du
refrain mais le problème c'est que je
n'ai pas à m'occuper de savoir ce qui
est un proche d'une école de curé je
n'ai pas moi m'occuper lorsque je suis
avec ma feuille lorsque je règle ses
comptes en banque française
je n'ai pas m'occuper du tout de savoir
ce que peuvent penser les autorités d'un
collège
je crois qu il se trouve que j'ai
dérangé parce que j'avais la double à
double casquette à la fois des trains
d'un côté un professeur d'autres
écrivains en particulier dans ce secteur
joue en guadeloupe est un truc comme ça
gracq aussi simplement ce qui m'a
intéressé c'est en l'occurrence c'est
d'utiliser le vocabulaire le vocabulaire
du sacré vocabulaire religieux pour
célébrer le corps féminin parce que je
pense que la femme est profondément
dépositaire du sacré et du divin
les troubadours le pensait avant moi et
simplement évidemment j'ai renouer avec
cette tradition à laquelle est venu
s'associer vocabulaire surréaliste et
cela effectivement à à déranger quelques
purs et qui ne lisent pas gayot adoré le
livre j'en ai tonnes il a trouvé que
c'était le cantique des cantiques
passage alors vous pouvez nous retrouver
demain c'est moi c'est vraiment un sport
ouais ouais c'est ce qu'on dit alors un
prof c'est lâche ça n'arrête pas de
lécher s'allège le dirlo salesches
l'inspecteur sur scène il faut il faut
finir la phrase j'ai dit ceci un procès
lâche ça n'arrête pas de lécher la
preuve ça ne sera jamais tiré sur un
inspecteur aux inspecteurs le sait c'est
pour ça qu'il vient alors jugement il ya
eu un jugement là le 10 novembre été
condamné alors 50 mille balles pour
dommages et intérêts pour atteinte à la
respectabilité ou à l'honorabilité du
collège du collège c'est tout en fait il
faut que je reprenne r5 il n'en est pas
question
je n'écris pas des livres pour pays une
r5 et pourtant il se vend bien son
bouquin tu pourrais y aura payé tu
pourrais leur pv mais c'est à dire que
la bombe entre temps pour oublier qu'à
une croûte cassation qui a dit le 31
janvier 89 à 100 en s'appuyant
précisément sur la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme que les jus de
tarbes et pau avait violiste convention
l'article 10 relatif à liberté
d'expression et donc les juges barbé et
palois devant cet arrêt exemplaire qui
fait que régine deforges à part publié
le livre avec monaco vers les juges
évidemment tarder
n'est ce pas ne pouvant pas se venger
sur le livre sont magistraux l'auteur
est donc assez demeura qu il faut pas y
aller non non mais pourtant elle a vendu
combien allait bien il se trouve que le
seul livre interdit en france
actuellement est devenu un best-seller
puisque nous atteignons les gagnants les
quatre premiers exemples ne suis pas un
coup de pot pour toi parce que je veux
dire bon temps libre et pas été
interdite je serai toujours prof à
garaison
jusque là connu tu passerais pas la
télévision est ce que c'est pas une
chance puisqu'il était à faire est-ce
que tu remercies pas le seigneur de
temps en temps ah oui là bas moi je
serais la plage oui je pense que les je
pense que le président du tribunal de
grande instance de tarbes est beaucoup
plus fort que monsieur séguéla
ouais il prend moins cher ça c'est sûr
mais surtout j'ai beaucoup aimé le
combat serait je vais prochainement
retourner en justice parce que j'avais
fait rappelle maintenant ça dort il
attendrait 4pm de l'express tu peux
continuer oui alors à part ça donc
maintenant tu écris dans les eaux
internationales qui tirent sur tout le
monde pour tous qu'ils viennent d'un
niveau international je pratique mon
bateau préféré le bâlois où il marque la
pure nvr durée de vie est donc là je
déplore profondément la la chute du mur
de berlin ce qu'il y avait des peintres
qui peignait sur ce mur qui n'ont pas
achevé leurs toiles je trouve que la
gamme et prix de l'artiste qui est
insupportable et donc je me bats pour
cela que c'est une oeuvre d'art on a
cassé une oeuvre d'art d'autant que dans
l'atlantique dans cette fente sèche par
sept fentes sèche du mur de berlin vont
nous revenir quelques vieux papistes
d'orientaux insupportable qui vont venir
trinquer à créer tchin tchin j'adore
avec tous les spas les les intégrismes
qui monte de la méditerranée la france
va devoir se secouer pour défendre ces
principes voltairien est ce que tu es
prêt pour faire une interview use pardon
c'est comme le tir au pigeon d'argile
bon alors tu attends que je descende
évidemment avec une nuit passée je
commence par jean edern hallier
jean-edern hallier c'est le mc enroe de
la littérature c'est à dire c'est à dire
que c'est un homme qui monte sans arrêt
aux filles et de son propre langage
et je suis tout à fait
d'abord je sensible à la présence de
l'homme sur le ring on repense toujours
ali d'être dans les médias les médias
c'est le forum c'est l'agora et jeudi
que le mystream léon daudet à léon
daudet c'est l'insolence absolue que je
veux dire c'est le premier écrivain à
avoir senti ce qu est un député témara
siens quand même
oui bon bien moment toutes les façons je
place le style au dessus au dessus de
tout je veux dire je préfère un
maurrassien style et un social-démocrate
vulgaire ni angloys les angoisses et là
c'est vraiment le comment dire d'emblée
on doit cesser le groom c'est le groupe
12h20 bernard henri lévy la nar henri
lévy c'est l'agité du bo l'agité 100
vocal
ça me paraît être je veux dire d'abord
c'est la revue globaux si c'est à dire
c'est de l'antisémitisme comme un fonds
de commerce tout ça je n'aime pas trop
que je n'aime pas ce tombeau de penser
failli ne pas trop ça non et puis la
chanson française il est beaucoup france
gall il admissible il admissible
alors après anne sinclair anne sinclair
je ne venais pas qu'un journaliste se
balade avec entre les mains un e
mont-blanc parce que le mont blanc c'est
fait pour les écrivais je pense que le
mont blanc c'est un burin pour le temps
qu'ils durent pas très grave il ne faut
pas il ne faut pas le laisser entre les
mains
côté habitants du temps qui passe autant
lara autant-lara 27e
c'est un personnage qui me permet de
cracher sur globe parce que je m'étonne
que la revue blood haye
je veux dire oui c'est vrai je comprends
pas l'étonnement de la rue drogue qui va
interroger d'antisémite et qui
s'étonnent automne antisémite eux
tiennent des propos antisémites
ça me rappelle la fée de la sphère
d'arqués nouvelles de pellepoix avec
l'interroger par l'express absolue c'est
la même démarche tout ça le pen le pen
je n'aime pas les gens qui vous tourne
le reste je veux dire que a est lui
censé démontrer non parce que je veux
dire où aujourd'hui il passe son temps à
vouloir faire taire les arabes alors que
najibullah des spécialités les faire
parler
françois mitterrand françois mitterrand
un très grand écrivain puisqu'il a écrit
le coup d'état permanent
ce à tous les socialistes dont oubliés
dont un écrivain une seule dernière
question mon cher question imagine que
tu sois encore prof à garaison et puis
un jour tu vois arriver une petite
fatima comme ça avec un petit foulard
sur la filature
je lui dit fatima enlève tout j'adore
parce que tu as de beaux cheveux et
quelle est donc cette religion qui
t'empêche de lâcher ces choses ont
avancé incorrigible je crois je crois je
crois que je fous le bordel dans l'école
voilà je refoule nan je refais le bordel
dans l'intolérance dans le mépris de
leurs familles je m'agenouille devant
fatima devant sa beauté et ses yeux
noirs des corrections de ne rien rater
de finale andy tu es abonné vous mettez
un pouce bleus